I want to start today by saying that I
saw your performance on the White House
correspondence dinner and I thought you
were fantastic I thought you were
absolutely fantastic and I've done that
venue uh I've played that thing twice uh
once uh uh uh under Clinton but the
hardest one was following Obama which uh
I mean it was almost like he was hosting
the Daily Show he had audio visual he
had you know they had all these stuff he
had all these writers working on it he
had uh I mean it was perfectly produced
I think he spent more time on that White
House correspondence and he did I bet
the economy tanked that the week that he
did the correspondence Center and he
just you know and so my experience was
I'm sure it's maybe it's the same but
you sit with the first lady is that what
was that your experience sit right next
to Joe Biden yeah and my experience was
I'm sitting next to Michelle Obama
and Obama's up there and he's killing
and I know I'm supposed to follow him
and I've got all these Jokes which I
think are pretty good I've worked hard
on it
but um he's they don't let you know what
what the president's gonna do and the
president gets to go first so you're
there with all these jokes you've been
working on for six months and they're
saying Obama's up there and he'll he'll
do one that's kind of close to something
that I was gonna do yeah because it's
all the same stuff in the news so I'm
trying to flip through all my blue cards
and take out the ones that he's touching
to drop them but at the same time
Michelle Obama's talking to me and she's
saying so your children are how old now
Conan and at one point and it's so funny
because she's because she's the greatest
she's such a lovely I've I've friendly
with her she's such a lovely person
she's the star in every room she's
beautiful she's really funny but in this
one moment I'm thinking would you please
leave me alone
oh god I've got to figure out if he's
doing my my debt ceiling joke or not I
can't remember who it was next to Trevor
Noah last year when Trevor did the
correspondence dinner but Trevor came up
there and was like straight laser
focused on his set and whoever it was on
one side of Trevor somebody was like
well why aren't you talking to Tre why
didn't you talk to Trevor
you know like he was focusing on his
stuff yeah he didn't have time to chit
chat it isn't is the way not to do
comedy is to make the comedian sit out
in front of the audience for an hour and
a half and then watch someone else go up
and get the
yeah like and and uh it's just it's so
it's a crazy kind of show business but
it's a fascinating experience and uh I
later got to talk on this program I got
to talk to President Obama and I said
you know
it's so unfair because you were so I
said you're so good and you've got all
the best material and and the you are
the most powerful person in the world
and comedy is all about status and you
get to go first
and then with no ceremony the minute
he's done they just go like Zuma go to
Brian no buffer no buffer nothing and he
said yeah yeah
yeah he said yeah I uh yeah I know I
know it's not fair but uh
I don't care
I thought that it's just so true what
does he care and then Biden Biden closes
with this dark Brandon joke which I
guess is like his alter ego yeah with
the sunglasses yeah and so then he's
standing there while I'm being
introduced still milking yeah milking
yeah still playing in the room and now I
have to walk past him to get some
insulin come on man you just rip just go
leave
just get the hell out of here it's not
you know it's funny it's not it's uh
it's not about the comedian on those
nights that's the other thing Joe
Biden's in my ear I'm going over cards
and then my writers are texting hey man
kellyanne Conway's in the room hey I'm
on Twitter right now turns out fauci did
show up if you have a fancy joke maybe
you should add a voucher and then
they're just ganging jokes in the
WhatsApp thread and I'm like guys
please shut the shut the yes yeah
but thanks for that information Bill
Barr is here oh okay cool oh Caitlyn
Jenner's here okay cool and it's a lot
but it's just trying to figure out at
that point where to add a joke I would
say that's when the set for me was like
okay these are the jokes yes fouchy all
right maybe and then Biden goes up Biden
stepped on
I had a Rupert Murdoch Fox News joke
that I just threw out all together
because Biden's was funnier yep and I
just I could do mine but it's not gonna
why even bother and then his Tucker
Carlson and Don Lemon stuff hit so hard
that I reordered yeah I changed the
batting order to create more space
between those two topics for me I was
doing the same thing like this joke
comes out this joke comes out okay Obama
just hit that this joke comes out this
joke's still okay but it flips up here
now because it's got to go earlier to
sort of tag what he said and you're
doing all that while the uh most
important
woman in the country is chatting you up
about you know what college do you think
your daughter might be interested in we
talked about Alabama in the South and
barbecue and and I was nervous in a
weird way because like I like my first
inclination when I spoke with it was
just to go don't worry you're safe yeah
like is this are you are you just gaming
me to find out what I'm gonna say about
sure yeah exactly because there's a lot
of that the week of get DMS from
people that particular news
organizations hey man how you been you
ready for Saturday I know what you're
trying to do you're trying to butter me
up yeah so I don't go after you yeah so
you know she was she was very nice but
we're not talking policy and how to
solve immigration right it's just oh
Alabama Barbecue tastes different from
Carolina Barbecue yes you're right it
does and then how how
for me and I don't know if this was
right
but I chose to also have a care of
concern
for how the outside world would consume
my performance because everyone goes oh
it's corporate
treated like a corporate gig for
an auto manufacturer company you're just
going to do your car jokes car industry
jokes and they're gonna like them but
yeah but there's people are going to
watch this later and I kind of want to
have a joke that they kind of yeah
would relate to so how do we balance the
two and so then it just became
how to use pop culture yep in there as
kind of the glue like for as long as you
hear a word of a thing that you
recognize and you're familiar with yeah
like the joke at the top about the Fox
News I'm not going to do any jokes about
Dominion because Dominion will come
after you matter of fact Dominion is my
favorite voting machine
if you want the truth have dominion in
the booth yeah such a great joke yeah so
then the tag was
if there's people there's the original
joke was if there's two people you don't
want to see in court it's dominion and
cardi B yeah either you know the cardi B
four million defamation suit story yep
or you don't yeah then one of my writers
I got to give credit to Lily Lily
blumpkin uh she's over at The Daily Show
Lily goes also Gwyneth Paltrow yes and I
go ah because I just I don't you why in
that world but guess what what she which
is smart and credit to your writer that
and and you for seeing that or or that
resonating with you is okay now you've
let everybody into the tent because if
you don't know cardi B
you definitely know that means you were
definitely following gwyneth's trial and
saying uh you know and so I mean that's
that brings up one tag informs you about
the tag you don't understand yeah what I
appreciated too you were hitting both
sides
you were hitting both sides which
doesn't always happen you know what I
mean and I thought uh so yeah you can
get up there and you can go after Tucker
Carlson but you're also had plenty of
stuff on Don Lemon and it was pretty
clear that you were not playing
favorites with the right or the left
which I think is really important right
now the biggest debate
within assembling the whole set was when
do we hit Biden do you hit them before
or after Trump to set up the whole idea
of oh no I'm gonna go at the Liberals
too sure but if you go and buy them too
soon
you lose the whole room yep because you
haven't earned their trust with any job
it's like so what do you do yeah so we
just we we stacked the set with what I
like to call soft targets first
that I feel like everybody in the room
will be okay with so Fox News Tucker
Santos yep Don Lemon right and then
Trump a little bit but not too much
Trump as to not make it think that this
whole thing is about Trump yep
then you go into everybody else I think
uh you're you had this great joke about
you know
um
you know France is burning to the ground
because they people do not want to work
an extra two years
they want to retire at 62 not 64. and
they're literally burning Paris and he
said when we have a guy here who's 81 or
80 and is begging us to get to work for
four more years and to me that was I
mean I was laughing really hard but it's
also so fun to see
Biden has to laugh you know and it's
also a really funny joke it's a really
funny joke that you can relate to and
it's not but I thought what was really
smart is the first thing you do when you
got up to the podium because you got to
get them early first thing when you got
to the pilgrims you said oh there's I
think you left some documents up here
first joke and it's just silly because
it's so silly that he accidentally left
some top secret documents at the podium
and so and they cut to him and he laughs
and it's like you know that's to me
that's great because you broke the ice
and it's also it's such a silly joke
like you know what I mean it's it's it's
silly that he gets up on the podium and
leaves some top secret documents I was I
was howling at that it was great to have
right away